Alvin Einstein this is my life we've got
to hand it to you mr. Feeny you sure
know how to make an impression we'll
never forget all the life lessons you
threw our way and how you always saw
something special in little Cory
Matthews you watched him grow up get
married and have children of his own and
you were always there to offer advice
and support they don't make them like
you anymore mr. Feeny Boy Meets World
will go down in history as one of the
best TV series of the 90s in fact some
might even say that it was close to
perfect well except for all of those
blot holes of course we've got 10 of the
biggest mistakes in Boy Meets World
lined up for you keep watching to find
out the real reason Eric and Jack
graduated from university a very
mysterious aging process before Joshua
came along there were only two Matthews
brothers but when Cory and Eric went off
to college their parents Amy and Alan
chose to have another child and that's
where things get a little wonky less
than one year passes between the end of
the series and Joshua's birth so you can
just imagine how shocked viewers were
when Joshua showed up looking and
talking like a full-on toddler that's
one very mature looking baby this
sibling debacle on more than one
occasion the showrunners of Boy Meets
World introduced siblings to the viewers
only to erase them off of the face of
the earth Shawn had a sister named Stacy
who was only ever mentioned in one
single episode
then there was Shawn's half-brother
Eddie who never made it to his dad's
funeral and let's not forget about
topanga's sister nebula who picked a
finger up from Cory's house only to
vanish into thin air if only getting rid
of pesky siblings were that easy I would
walk 300 miles one of the most
heartbreaking episodes of Boy Meets
World was the one when Topanga and Cory
broke up because his family was moving
to Pittsburgh seeing these to say
goodbye was excruciating but by the end
of the episode we'd be crying for
different reasons
Quarry opens his front door to find a
soaking wet Topanga on his doorstep
she tells pouria that she ran away to be
with him but wait Orange Pittsburgh and
Philadelphia like 300 miles apart
we seriously hope Topanga got on a bus
instead of running back to Cory on her
own two feet what happened to mr. Turner
mr Turner was by far one of the best
characters in Boy Meets World
he was Cory Shawn and topanga's English
teacher but he was so much more than
that mr. Turner
acted as Shawn's legal guardian
confidant and friend look Shawn this
hasn't been the easiest year for me
either you know I mean going from a
single guy to raising a 15 year old was
not on my to-do list
in fact it sometimes appeared as though
mr. Turner loved Shawn more than his own
father dead
mr Turner appeared in seasons 1 and 2
only to completely disappear after
suffering a motorcycle accident same
character new actor younger viewers may
not have noticed but Cory's little
sister Morgan disappeared from the show
only to reappear later on the series
Lilly Nick's a the child actor who first
portrayed Morgan wound up quitting the
show and eventually the role was given
to Lindsay Ridgeway if that wasn't weird
enough it wasn't uncommon for actors to
play more than one role like when Willie
Garson portrayed Leonard Spinelli
Mervin and Merrill Lynch all at the same
time Romeo and Juliet a lot of English
teachers make it a point to read Romeo
and Juliet with their students so we
weren't at all surprised when mr. Feeny
taught Cory's class about Romeo and
Juliet in the pilot episode of the
series mr. Feeny who cares about some
guy who killed himself over some dumb
girl but we were surprised when later on
in the series Cory came face to face
with the Shakespearean play and acted
like it was his first time hearing about
it Topanga goes to Disneyland in the
episode titled the happiest show on
earth
Topanga wins a trip and goes to Disney
World but not before getting into a huge
fight with Cory determined to win her
back Cory and Shawn take a plane to
surprise her at Disney World
in the episode witches of Pennbrook Cory
and Topanga plan a trip and she reveals
that she's never been on a plane before
which isn't exactly true Cory and
Shawn's friendship timeline throughout
the series we're told that Shawn and
Cory have been friends since they were
about six years old but at some point
mr. Feeny says that Shawn used to live
in Oklahoma he also states that Shawn
moved around a lot and attended five
different schools before moving to
Philly
so technically Shawn and Cory couldn't
have met until they were about 12 years
old Cory and topanga's love story
Cory explains the exact moment that he
fell in love with Topanga on three
separate occasions but all of them are
different scenarios at first he says he
fell in love with her when she pushed
him onto his locker
then he recalls a moment when they were
catching fireflies as kids and then he
goes on to say that he fell for her when
they were toddlers playing at the park
so which one is it Cory University
graduates we loved how Eric and Jack
graduated from Penn Brook University
together but couldn't help but notice
that they had only completed three years
of school since they weren't the
sharpest tools in the shed fans found
this a little hard to believe
so some viewers have theorized that they
dropped out and lied about it
who was your favorite character from Boy
Meets World sound off in the comments
and thanks for tuning in don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to the
things we'll catch you next time